so wait so we're days from Halloween so
do you get into it with your kids I love
Halloween yeah look Halloween I I think
I rediscovered it when I had kids right
like it kind of just become this kind of
annoying holiday and then all of a
sudden I had kids and all of a sudden I
felt their excitement of wanting to
dress up and everything and I think my
son's first one was a fireman yeah so
he's he's the fireman over there with
that glowing suit and I went so far as
to dress up as Spider-Man
and I didn't know this but it enabled me
to just be like normal because they
can't see me nobody could see what it is
I love Halloween right and so kids
thought I was really Spiderman which was
interesting because they wanted to hit
me and yeah so I was like hey yeah yeah
it was what it was but like I was I was
happy because I was I was working on a
show at that time so I was actually in
shape and could stand in that position
um and get up and it up from that
position because it wasn't always that
way yeah it happens to the best of us
yeah um did you enjoy Halloween as a kid
though like I loved it
a grown-up even
I actually don't have time for a party
unless it's dress up okay I just think
it's fun okay because you really get to
see who people are yeah like why did you
come as that yeah I don't remember any
Halloween parties really as a kid
because I think it was like you did like
parties at school and then it was like
trick-or-treating that's right but when
I was a kid I was I was a different kind
of person like I I I was one of those
kids who stole candy from little kids
and
wait what are you judging me yes
wait you're like the nicest guy ever but
but where I grew up like it happened to
me
okay you know what I mean someone stole
it that's a really nice justification
yeah and
it's beautiful yeah know but everyone
was doing Al everyone was doing it
happened to me so like people just walk
up and take a vicious cycle yeah it was
like bigger kids like this was like when
E.T was out yeah yeah so it was
different it was like someone said Hey
kid give me a candy you're like this
yeah and you give it to him and then you
know because you didn't want to get beat
up and so you give it to them and then
you just go get some more you go get
some more so when you got older you said
hey go get some more you'd be all right
you'd be all right go get some more oh
my gosh yeah make some tough I would see
I'm sneaky though like as a parent so I
can't really judge you because I totally
steal their candy while they're sleeping
they go to bed yeah yeah and I'm like I
find my favorite things and I'm like
yeah that's mine and they won't remember
I'll be like oh I don't I don't know I
don't I guess you didn't get that I
didn't make it to the back I lie yeah I
I act yeah as best as I can
as best as I can on Halloween night
because I'm like okay kids it's great
you got your candy this is wonderful
listen you got a big day tomorrow at
school yeah so we can't eat all of this
candy now just give it to me you guys go
to bed and it'll be here in the morning
you can take little pieces every day
moving forward that's what we do yeah
that's what I do them cats go to sleep I
sit on the couch
I start combing you're like oh I haven't
had a bit of honey in a minute I get all
of the Reese's Cups yeah that I can I
love receipts and I like leave like one
or two in there in their baskets so they
don't feel like I don't know you know
that they've been they're not that storm
yet yeah so I put those in the freezer
and I hide them in a special spot in the
freezer in the freezer yeah if you don't
freeze your Reese's cups I have not I
freeze grapes I love Frozen grapes
that's good or frozen Ding Dongs yeah I
haven't done that in a minute like since
my 20s but like that's good see Oreo is
good anytime yeah anytime like warm
frozen do you do the chocolate covered
ones too hey yeah yeah oh yeah yeah it
feels good yeah no it's Happy Times well
I heard that you liked Reese's so I
thought I would bring you some I think
Justin might have some some reason
coming out I think so no I think yeah
oh my God
that's that's up thank you Justin
yeah
here's my okay oh that's nice that's
nice wait here's my thing let's be real
though I'm gonna I'm gonna hand it to
y'all reasons right now because see this
ratio this is off
this is not you think it's going to be
the same it's not you got to go for this
is not the right ratio I just wanted to
pull this out to help you out as a
company
um it's not that it's not the right
ratio it's not
take it from me
[Applause]
um it's not it's not as good I'm like
there's too much chocolate there's not
enough peanut whatever
[Music]
[Applause]